no
[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 hoy dedicamos escala en parís a la
historia de la lucha de las guerrillas
en el continente latinoamericano sus
objetivos su influencia en la
geopolítica en la evolución en los
gobiernos y también sus fracasos y lo
hacemos a través de un libro que se
acaba de publicar guerrillas en américa
latina' 1959 1989 hacer realizar y
deshacer la revolución y tenemos en
línea a su autor toma peón desde
aguascalientes méxico donde reside toma
bienvenido
bueno usted es especialista en
relaciones internacionales experto en
américa latina y la revolución cubana
ocupa un lugar muy importante en su
libro y vamos a empezar a hablar
hablando de cuba porque tal vez estemos
asistiendo a un momento histórico con
esas protestas por la falta de comida
por la falta de medicinas y también el
pidiendo libertad cuba que fue con su
revolución en 1959 la cuna de esas
guerrillas en latinoamericanas es la
primera vez que los cubanos salen a las
calles para pedir libertad y un cambio
de régimen
estamos ante el principio del final del
sistema cubano toma
bueno primero hubo un punto bueno hubo
varios antecedentes en los 90 y en los
dos minutos a finales de durante el
periodo especial en tiempos de paz
que eran los 90 en 2000 en 1994 hubo una
serie de manifestaciones de este tipo
sociales contra en la escasez de comida
y de bienes de consumo extra que se
llevaba el mal y conocí
segundo hubo en 2003 la primavera negra
y la historia de contestaciones contra
el gobierno y también la gracia de
representes punta
también hay que tocar con el tema de los
movimientos anti castristas están desde
el viaje de luchar por su influencia
contra el gobierno de esto
como explica que un movimiento
revolucionario como el cubano socialista
que defendía una sociedad más justa
igualitaria
que hizo la revolución con esa guerrilla
haya caído en la represión en la
persecución a opositores a periodistas
haya cortado internet
antes de eso hubo una serie de
represiones contra los que no estaban a
favor de su revolución por ejemplo que
sea el régimen de funcionario en cuba en
nicaragua en los 80 todos los que
estaban considerados como los enemigos
del gobierno de la revolución de sus
ideales pues fueron
las víctimas de una represión estatal y
medidas gobiernan
en otro de los países que en su libro
llama a estado revolucionario aparte de
cuba es justamente nicaragua en de hecho
el presidente ortega fue una figura
central del frente sandinista sin
embargo si hacemos un balance es
bastante terrible el sandinismo actual
de ortega nada o poco tiene que ver con
esa lucha de los años 70 y en las
últimas semanas también hemos visto
detenciones a opositores a líderes
estudiantiles a candidatos para las
elecciones de noviembre en que se ha
convertido el régimen de ortega
nicaragua
danielle ortigueira
el presidente del gobierno sandinista ya
y su tienda y tuvo otra vez el poder en
2006 después de elecciones
presidenciales y desde entonces
estableció como un gobierno en que
tienen y es dominado por su poder y su
influencia a través también de pareja la
primera dama y vemos que como en los 80
hay una serie de dificultades económicas
políticas de una deriva autoritaria del
gobierno sandinista del sandinista ahora
y además hablando del sandinismo en el
antagonista zandio vimos que hay varios
eran instante mismos único de revolución
y abrazos
no todas las guerrillas dieron lugar a
estados llamados revolucionarios
tenemos por ejemplo el caso de las farc
en colombia que controlaron llegaron a
encontrar mucho mucho territorio pero
que finalmente bueno acabaron por firmar
esos acuerdos de paz en en 2016 con juan
manuel santos entonces presidente unos
acuerdos que no están siendo nada
fáciles de implementar y que han dado
lugar a que haya una disidencia
de las farc que continúe activa cuáles
son las razones
primero hay que describir un poco el
caso colombiana colombia es un país que
durante su historia vivió muchos muchas
gracias civiles y conflictos internos y
antes del nacimiento de las farc esto
matar por una década de crisis nacional
guerra la violencia y donde nació
las primeras guerrillas y luego las
artes hablamos de las farc es también
ahí
otros grupos como el lg y vélez
esta vez
desde ese día
[Música]
enfrentamientos las negociaciones de paz
etcétera quiz que nunca al final lugar
por el momento terminar en paz nacional
y hacia dónde va la responsabilidad de
que no se pueda es muy complicado no
después de tantos años de lucha
me parece que es por la presencia de
múltiples actores que se involucran en
el gobierno grupos instruccionales para
grupos paramilitares las farc es las
otras guerrillas el narcotráfico
justamente qué papel juega el
narcotráfico en la financiación de las
guerrillas
emergió con una economía relacionada con
el narcotráfico desde colombia hasta
méxico nicaragua perú y en varios casos
el narcotráfico fue una fuente de
financiamiento para las acciones de
reducción como el sendero luminoso en
perú como para el tope y que subir jugar
en méxico y en
sí mismo en nicaragua
sin embargo es un poco más complicado
hoy todo está bien
cómo
cuál ha sido
o sea quiénes son los herederos de las
guerrillas revolucionarias quiénes son
los que usted llama neo revolucionarios
según yo es como una serie de gobierno
de la nueva izquierda y la vuelta a la
izquierda y los dos mil que fueron
google gobiernos que accedieron al poder
en brasil con lula en argentina con
kirchner
bachelet chile en ecuador
tomen en salvador y que se caracterizan
con nuevas formas de izquierda el
socialismo del siglo 21
altermundialismo o tercer mundial ismo
etcétera
morales también gorilla
y me gustaría también comentar con usted
el caso de méxico y de los zapatistas en
chiapas podemos decir que los zapatistas
tuvieron muchísimo auge a finales de los
años 90 a principios de los 2000 pero no
consiguieron extender esa lucha a todo
el territorio mexicano
y han creado una especie de de estado
dentro del estado no con sus reglas en
chiapas cuéntenos
era una nacieron en 1994 que es como un
año de crisis para méxico una crisis
política una crisis económica con la
elección presidencial que termina con el
asesinato de luis donaldo colosio
el nacimiento de esa grilla cuando sepas
hay quien diga que esa que ya es
totalmente relacionada con el entorno
indígena
vaya
y qué
es muy diferente al de todas las que
fuimos de méxico
y es que según usted hay alguno
el país en el que las guerrillas hayan
evolucionado hacia un régimen un sistema
político estable y duradero
según lo que ingresé en mi libro y no
cuando hay ejemplos así porque al final
el proyecto de la y en sí mismo pudimos
considerar que es como
la ilustración en estas épocas de la
crisis de las vías clásicas del juego
político democrático o no es decir que a
menudo nacen como facciones del partido
comunista y existen hacer una lucha
armada porque consideran que otras vías
más clásicas no funcionan
pues muchísimas gracias toma por esta
entrevista con radio francia
internacional y france 24 recordemos que
usted es el autor de este libro
guerrillas en américa latina' 1959 1989
y le deseamos mucho éxito
muchas gracias y muchísimas gracias a
todos ustedes por habernos acompañado ya
saben que nos pueden seguir por internet
en rf y mundo.com france24 puntocom
hasta pronto amigos
[Música]